Herkese merhabalar öncelikle bu nazik
davet için çok teşekkür ederim ve çok
heyecanlı olduğum sizlerin karşısına çok
heyecanlı olduğumu baştan söylemek
istiyorum Burcu Boran Ben Sea Turkey
şirketinin kurucu ortağıyım çevre
mühendisiyim 15 yıldır da yaklaşık
sürdürülebilirlik konusunda çalışıyorum
ve Evet 15 yıl önce de aslında iklim
değişikliği konuşuyorduk
sürdürülebilirlik konuşuyorduk
ama mutlu eden konuştuk ki bu konu artık
hakettiği değeri bulmaya başladı
günümüzde buralarda gençler ve sizlerle
Konuşma imkanımız var
İnsanoğlu Aslında var olduğundan beri
Doğa olaylarını anlamlandırmaya çalışmış
Yağmur yağmış Güneş açmış ve kar yağmış
ve bunlar belirli bir döngü içerisinde
oldukça da Bereket gelmiş yağmurun
yağması ile toprak ıslanıyor
güneşin açmasıyla tohumlar filizleniyor
ve İnsanoğlu Karnını doyuruyor yalnız
belli bir süre sonra biz bu karın
doyurma meselesini biraz yanlış anlamaya
başladık galiba karnımızı doyurmak
yerine gözümüzü doyurmaya çalıştık ve o
noktada da çok başarılı olduğumuz
söylenemez
Dünyanın bir ucundan gıda getirmeyi lüks
saydık dünyanın başka bir ucunda üretim
yapıp onu başka bir ülkede etiketlemeyi
arkasından Başka bir ülkede Bu ürünü
satmayı da başarırız zannettik
sanıyorum Bu başarı tanımlamasında bir
hatamız oldu başarı Gerçekten bu muydu
yani antik çağlardan beri var olan
petrol sadece son yüzyıldaki insanların
hakkımı veya antik çağlardan beri
toprağın altında var olan mineraller
Sadece
bu minerallerin çıkarılması için bu
minerallerin taşınması için verilen
maliyetlerle mi hesaplanmalı
burada bir oturup düşünmemiz gerekiyor
galiba ve işte sürdürülebilirliğin
tanımı da tam burada çıkıyor bugünün
ihtiyaçlarını gelecek nesillerin
ihtiyaçlarını gözeterek tüketmek
fazlasını tüketmememiz gerekiyor ve
Bugün şunu çok net söyleyebilirim iklim
değişikliği sürdürülebilirliğin itici
gücü ve 2050 hedeflerine baktığımızda da
2050'de dünya net Zira olmayı hedefliyor
yani aldığıyla verdiğini dengelemeye
çalışıyor sanayiden kaynaklı
faaliyetlerimizden oluşan emisyonların
dünyanın absorbe edebildiği emisyonlarla
dengede olmasını sağlamaya çalışıyoruz
bu bu aslında mümkün mü Bunu başarabilir
miyiz şöyle Bununla ilgili hedefler
koyduk ve buna şunu diyoruz İnsanoğlu
Acaba bunu başarabilir mi yani
iklimlerin değişmesine iklimlerin
değişmesi durumunda oluşacak aşırı hava
olaylarına Rüzgarlara sellere
fırtınalara yükselen denizlere karşı
adaptasyonu ve uyum sağlayabilecek mi
bugün asıl sorumuz şu; biz insanlık
olarak iş dünyası olarak iklim
değişikliği adaptasyonlu ve uyumunu
sağlayabiliyor muyuz sağlayamıyor muyuz
bunu başarabilecek miyiz Ben inanıyorum
ki bunu başaracağız
heybemiz biraz dolu maalesef sanayi
devrimi var olduğundan beri dünyaya
emisyonları salmaya devam ettik ve Bu
hedeflere giderken de biraz daha
emisyonumuz olmaya devam edecek
Dolayısıyla heybemiz doluyken dedik ki;
Biz bari bir buçuk derece
ısıtsın bu dünya sadece bir buçuk derece
ile bunu sınırlı tutalım Bu o kadar da
kolay bir şey değil Bu aslında büyük
değişimler gerektiriyor Dolayısıyla Eğer
bizim hedefimiz bir buçuk derece
ısınmayla yaşamaya adapte olmaksa buna
uyum sağlamaksa şunu benzetebiliriz 37
buçuk derece ile yaşayacağız
37,5 derece değildi 38 olsa bir buçuk
derece değilde 2 derece ısınsak ne olur
biyoçeşitlilikteki biyoçeşitlilik
kayıpları
yüzde
15-10 seviyelerinden yüzde 15-20
seviyelerine çıkıyor bu durumdan iklim
değişikliğinden etkilenecek insan sayısı
bir buçuk derece ile 2 derece olması
arasında 15 milyondan fazla etkileniyor
ve iklim değişikliği kaynaklı göçmenler
oluşmaya başlıyor O yüzden de bugün
elimizden geldiğince En azından bir
buçuk derece hedefine ulaşacak şekilde
çalışmaları yapmalıyız Bu Kolay mı diye
soracak olursanız Evet almamız gereken
çok aksiyon var
Peki biz bireyler olarak bir şey
yapabilir miyiz önce ona bakalım Biz
birey olarak ne yapabiliriz
Öncelikle tüketime dur demek zorundayız
bunu bir şekilde fark etmemiz gerekiyor
aldığımız herhangi bir ürünün bir
düğmenin bile üzerindeki o fiyat
etiketinin dışında bir maliyeti var
aslında gelecek nesillerin kaynağını
kullanıyoruz onu üretiyoruz Ve üstelik o
bertaraf olacağı noktada da gelecek
nesillerin kaynaklarını kirletiyoruz
bunu hakkımız var mı Buna bir düşünmemiz
gerekiyor
Ben tüketici olarak buna dur demeni çok
kolay olmadığını biliyorum umuyorum
başarabiliriz umuyorum daha farkında
yaşayabiliriz
ancak bir de iş dünyası boyutu var işi
iş dünyası boyutu var konunun iş
dünyasını baktığımızda Ben iş
dünyasından çok büyük bir beklenti
içerisindeyim Aslında bakarsanız Çünkü
bir ürünün satışından eğer gelir elde
ediyorsanız Bu ürünün içerisindeki
hammadde Bu ürünü kullanım aşaması Bu
ürünün bertarafı noktalarını
sorgulamanızı beklerim bir örnek verecek
olursak bir elektronik ürünü ele alalım
bir elektronik ürün üretildi doğada
hammaddeler hammadde elde edilen bazı
materyaller kullanıldı metal malzemeler
kullanıldı plastik malzemeler kullanıldı
o ürün üretildi arkasından o ürün
Bizler tarafından kullanıldı ve ürün
bertaraf ediliyor bu noktaların hepsinde
bu aşamaların hepsinde bir şirket şunu
diyebilir mi Ben Bu ürünün Bu ürünün
üretilmesi için kullandığımız madende
kullandığımız
madenin şartları Beni ilgilendirmez
Çocuk işçi mi çalıştırıldı
Doğa ne kadar tahrip edildi endemik
türler ne kadar yok edildi Beni
ilgilendirmez veya Bu ürünün ömrü
yeterince uzun değil ürünü alıyorsunuz
Bir sene içinde bozuluyor tekrar
yenisini alıyorsunuz Bu Beni
ilgilendirmez veya bu ürünü atık oluyor
atıyorsunuz Eğer şanslıysanız bertaraf
tesislerine gidiyor ama büyük bir
ihtimalle ya Düzenli depolamaya gidiyor
ya da vahşi depolama depolamaya gidiyor
ve içerisindeki pillerden kaynaklı o
ağır metaller zaten bizim sınırlı olan
su kaynaklarımızı kirletiyor
bir şirket diyebilir mi ki bunlar benim
için önemli değil dememeli
sürdürülebilirliğin temelinde duyarlılık
felsefesi yatıyor ve ben çok şanslıyım
ki bugün burada gençlerle Sizin
karşınızda şunu söyleyebilirim İçinizde
Aslında İyiyi kötüyü doğruyu yanlışı
hepsini biliyorsunuz ve inanın İş
dünyasının içerisinde bunların hiçbiri
hiçbir zaman değişmiyor Sadece bazen
hayatın akışına fazlaca kapılıyoruz
Dolayısıyla
2030'a giderken mevcut teknolojileri
daha çok kullanarak mevcut
teknolojilerin yaygınlaşmasını
sağlayarak 2030 hedeflerine
ulaşabileceğini düşünüyorum ama 2050
hedefleri için sizin bu iyi bakışınıza
iş dünyasının mevcut operasyonlarını
tekrar gözden geçirmeye iyi niyetle ve
baştan kurgulamaya gerçekten ihtiyacımız
var sorun çekeceğini Biz çaldık
mevsimleri kendi döngüsü içerisinde
mevsimlerin kendi döngüsü içerisinde
hareket etmeye ihtiyacı var bizim o
etkiyi çekmemiz gerekiyor Dolayısıyla
bugün sorusunu sorabiliriz mevcut
alışkanlıklarımızla tamam mı yoksa devam
mı Çok teşekkür ediyorum
[Alkış]